the insurrection that took place at the
capitol on january 6
was one of the worst most violent
attacks
in the history of our country according
to the ruling elite
that comprises not just democrats but
also court jester conservatives
such as liz cheney the attack on this
building
on january 6 was the worst attack
on this capital since 1814
it was an attack on our constitution we
supported
what would have been the very best
option which was a bipartisan
independent commission the minority
leader opposed that
he lobbied against it in the senate and
the senate blocked it
the american people deserved to know
what happened
the people who did this must be held
accountable
there must be an investigation that is
nonpartisan
that is sober that is serious that gets
to the facts wherever they may lead
uh and at every opportunity the minority
leader
has attempted to prevent the american
people from understanding
what happened to block this
investigation
the first part wasn't true and the
second part is never going to happen
here's what really happened
the horn guy made a mess of nancy
pelosi's desk
and the smiley guy stole her lectern and
the only person to die by political
violence
was the trump supporter that the cops
shot and killed the good news here
is that even sometimes squishy
republicans
are waking up to how the liberal
establishment actually orchestrates
so many national episodes be they acts
of terror
global lockdowns or the brainwashing of
whole generations i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday is from
gwen and gold
who says i hope larry elder wins
california is too
beautiful a place to leave in the hands
of commies any longer
i would have to agree i love california
it's a very
beautiful place i don't think we should
see the ground at all i remember
back in the good old days when when
california was still
a livable place i can remember them in
part because i can look at old
photographs and when you want to
preserve your old photographs i strongly
recommend
you check out legacy box who are you
who who who i really want to know i want
to know who you are
is so tied up in your memories your
life your your little film reels your
pictures your photographs especially
when you've got photos of people who are
no longer with us and you know what i
bet i bet you've got them all in a box
right now
and i bet they're degrading and i bet
that sometimes they're getting lost
and if a fire or some other awful event
happens at your house they're gone
forever
legacy box will help you preserve
digitally
your past it's very simple you send in
your photos to legacy box they will
digitize them by hand they will send you
back all your photos and they will send
you
the digital copy so you can get that on
a thumb drive you get it on the cloud
you can get it however you want
this is so important to do now do not
put it off
right now get started future proofing
your memories today so you can gather
the family
and begin the trip down memory lane go
to legacy box dot com slash knowles
to get an incredible forty percent four
zero percent off your first order
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer send them in when you're
ready but just get it today
legacybox.com save 40 while supplies
last
the january 6th commission
is falling apart the january 6th
commission is a partisan
hack tactic to continue to do
what the democrats and liz cheney but i
repeat myself
have been trying to do for months now
which is to equate the horn guy dancing
at the capitol
with september 11th there was a 911
commission so we need a january 6th
commission
now it was a terrible idea to create the
commission in the first place
republicans
rightly fought against it because
if there's going to be a commission to
figure out why
some eccentric people danced around the
capitol probably there should be a
commission to figure out why
radical leftists burned down multiple
cities around the country for eight
months with the implicit and actually
sometimes
explicit support of elected democrats up
to and including the sitting vice
president of the united states don't you
think there should maybe be a commission
for that
if we're going to have a commission
about the smiley guy who took nancy
pelosi's
lectern i think probably there would be
so anyway the republicans try to shut it
down
doesn't totally work so they go and they
appoint people to the commission
and then as politico reported yesterday
nancy pelosi
rejected the conservative republicans
who would even sit on the allegedly
bipartisan commission
nancy pelosi rejected representative jim
banks from indiana
and representative jim jordan from ohio
who were both put on the the commission
by the gop leader kevin mccarthy
as a result of this and you got to give
mccarthy credit where credit's due
because mccarthy everyone goes after
mccarthy in part because
he's a little bit more of an
establishment figure and in part just
because he's the leader of the house gop
and so he's always going to be
irritating some people but you got to
give him credit where credit's due
as a result of pelosi's preposterous
action to kick off
a couple of conservatives on the
commission kevin mccarthy pulled
all of the gop members he said quote
this represents an egregious abuse of
power
and will irreparably damage this
institution
denying the voices of members who have
served in the military and law
enforcement as well as leaders of
standing committees has made it
undeniable that this panel has lost all
legitimacy and credibility
spoiler alert it never had any of those
things and it shows the speaker is more
interested in playing politics than
seeking the truth of course
unless speaker pelosi reverses course
and seats all five republican nominees
republicans will not be party to their
sham process and will instead pursue our
own investigation of the facts
good this is the right approach
democrats are going to do whatever they
want to do but instead of it being a
bipartisan bicameral commission into the
greatest tragedy in human history
the insurrection now it's going to be a
partisan
house of representatives propaganda
campaign
to to pretend that the horn guy is osama
bin laden
there has been some evidence that's come
out
that federal law enforcement knew
about planned demonstrations at and in
the capitol on january 6th
furthermore there's been some evidence
that's come out from revolver news
notably
that law enforcement officials were
involved
actually in orchestrating some of the
events of january 6th
now this sounds like a wild crazy
conspiracy theory
the what you're telling me michael that
the fbi
may be and i'm not not claiming this was
certainly the case but there is evidence
and there are reports of it
you telling me michael that the fbi had
some hand in what was going on on
january 6th
i am yeah i am telling you that first of
all
i know that everything gets memory hold
these days when it doesn't fit the
narrative who planted the bombs
remember we were told they discovered
bombs outside of the rnc and the dnc
who planted them we live in the age of
surveillance capitalism to use a popular
phrase we live in the age where there's
a camera
on every block there's cameras outside
of the rnc and the dnc and every other
building
the fbi was able to trace down every
single eccentric republican
who entered the capital on january 6 but
we can't trace down who planted bombs
allegedly outside of the rnc and the dnc
that's kind of weird
and and even beyond what happened on
january 6th
as buzzfeed nude news a left-wing outlet
is pointing out the
fbi very often has a role in some of
these alleged
terror attacks so notably and this is
from
from buzzfeed the conspiracy to kidnap
michigan governor gretchen whitmer do
you remember that that was a few months
ago
we were told that the radical far right
nazi fascist republicans were going to
go kidnap gretchen whitmer
well it turns out that the fbi
had a pretty pretty big role not just in
in executing this this action
but in planning it as well at least a
dozen
confidential fbi informants reportedly
assisted the quote-unquote investigation
into
this alleged extremist group and
this is the weirdest part some of the
informants
reportedly took leading roles in
the scheme they didn't just tell the
feds what was going on with the
extremist group
they didn't even just egg other people
along
they took leading roles in the alleged
plot
to kidnap the governor of michigan to
date
this according to buzzfeed one defendant
has formally accused the government of
entrapment
arguing that the fbi assembled the key
plotters
encouraged the group's anti-government
feelings
and gave its members military-style
training
and additional defendants have said that
they plan to make similar claims when
the cases which are divided now between
federal and state courts
go to trial within the next few months
if you want to see the long history of
this sort of thing i
i'd recommend you go head over to
revolver news right now they have a
great article on
five instances of the fbi in american
history
putting forward operations to encourage
acts of terrorism
because i get the fbi's legitimate role
in getting informants to thwart acts of
terrorism
but sometimes things get so far that it
seems like the cart
is leading the horse seems like the tail
is wagging
the dog this is always my view whenever
the
ku klux klan is brought up in the
mainstream media which is
frequently we're told there are all
these klansmen running around america i
strongly suspect
that roughly 99.3 percent of
self-described klansmen in america
are just fbi informants
informing on all of the other fbi
informants that i think it's a
completely
almost completely contrived phenomenon
to maintain i'm not even saying this is
through malice it might be just through
the incompetence
of the federal intelligence and law
enforcement agencies
but to maintain a boogie man that is
almost
entirely a phantom now when you go into
an auto port store and you want your
part probably
those auto parts you need are going to
be phantoms as well they're not going to
be there which is why
you got to go to rockauto.com your time
is important your energy is important
your dignity
is important so why would you waste all
three
in the brick and mortar auto parts store
that's going to pepper you with
questions and not have the auto parts
that you need and then they're going to
go online
almost certainly to rockauto.com they're
going to order the part they're going to
charge you twice as much and you're
going to have to wait several days to do
it at least maybe a week maybe two weeks
make your life easy go to rockauto.com
they've always got the lowest prices
possible they don't change the prices
based on what the market will bear
it's just you know it'll be the same
price tuesday morning as it will be
tuesday afternoon okay
the catalog is very easy to navigate so
easy even i can do it
head on over right now to rockauto.com
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then this is the most
important part
write knowles know w l e s in there how
did you hear about xbox
so they know that we sent you you can
send me a thank you note later on
rockauto.com
so the the criminals who are plotting
all of these terrible terrorist attacks
and their far
right fringe turns out a lot of those
criminals are
working for the government well if
everyone's an informant
then uh isn't the government just the
instigator here
speaking of criminals in government
rand paul rand paul
has just look he came here
to pass out pocket constitutions and
smackdown dr
fauci and i'm all out of pocket
constitutions so he's just smacking
fouchy
left and right in the senate hearings on
television news hits
and now in a letter to the doj because
rand paul
is referring dr fauci
to the doj for a criminal investigation
you kicked off
your questioning of dr fauci emphasizing
federal law
makes lying to congress a felony
punishable by up to five years in prison
is your belief based on the evidence
senator
that he lied before congress and broke
the law
yes and i will be sending a letter to
the department of justice asking for a
criminal referral
because he has lied to congress we have
scientists that will line up by the
dozens
to say that the research he was funding
was gain of function
he's doing this because he has a
self-interest to cover his tracks
and to cover his connection to wuhan lab
absolutely right
absolutely right we called it on the
show when dr fauci made that claim
you'll remember this was some months ago
because it was one of the funniest
claims that dr fauci has made
he says well first he just denies the
gain of function research you are wrong
senator that type of research is not
happening
then rand paul pushes him further around
he goes the gain of function research
was not
being funded and also it's totally cool
and i'm glad we funded it
it's almost true almost verbatim not
quite i took a little artistic liberty
but that was the point he made
we're not doing this but also it's
totally cool that we did this
so so rand paul is saying you know dr
fauci
this is not just some tv news hit where
you can lie to the american people with
impunity you are speaking under oath and
if you're lying then you're going to
purge
yourself and that is what rand paul
contends
dr fauci did and so there will be a
criminal investigation
if the doj takes it up which it probably
won't because it's being led by merrick
garland
now i do not want to live in a country
where for instance we always send the
former president to prison
you i mean it's fun to do the la corrupt
chance and i don't want to live in
trump's america yeah because you'd be in
jail hillary you know these are good
lines and i i like that
but i don't want to live in a country
where we just lock up our former
presidents
however right now
dr fauci first of all is more powerful
than just about any president
that we've had in quite a long time and
also
we need to be able to exercise political
power if the left is going to constantly
abuse its power
and make really audacious threats and
actually wield the government in that
way
then republicans need to be able to
wield political power
as well i'd prefer to live in a world in
which we didn't have to jail
powerful politicians however
this is the world we live in and so i
think these threats i'm not saying even
carrying it out but i'm saying the
threat at least the criminal
investigation at least
just the fact that the doj could look
into him would be
a good way to diminish the power of dr
fauci the
high pontiff of progressivism
because it's never going to end the
kovitz stuff is never going to end
15 days to slow the spread is
15 more than 15 months now to slow this
spread and now we've got the
delta and the lambda and the sigma and
the phi beta kappa variance
and we're going to put mask up again in
the fall and we're going to lock up
again
and probably can't go to church not all
the time not those numbers don't shake
hands
maybe we still have to negotiate with
the school school unions
it's it's just going to drag on forever
if we give them
that power here's an article this is one
of the most preposterous articles i've
seen in quite a while
i was going viral yesterday headline i'm
sorry
but it's too late alabama doctor on
treating
unvaccinated dying covid patients
covid deaths very very low right now
this is why everyone
is talking about the case numbers even
some republicans are falling into this
trap
of grabbing their pearls about the the
case numbers the diagnoses of kovid
the deaths are very very very low at
this point
and yet the public health establishment
is trying to get young people who face
very very very little risk from kovid
of any serious complications or death
they're trying to get them to take the
experimental drug
and they're i've mentioned before right
my view on the vaccine is not that it's
absolutely pure poison filled with
microchips that's going to
put 5g signals in your body frankly that
would be an improvement to my cell
service
and it's also not that the vaccine is
totally safe and there's no worry
whatsoever
obviously that's not the case there's
been plenty of evidence of myocarditis
periocarditis
blood clots in women the fda and the cdc
have admitted all of this stuff
so it i'm not saying either of those
things i'm suggesting
using prudence prudence
prudence on your medical risk prudence
on your political power if your school
is going to mandate that you get the
vaccine
maybe that's going to be cause for you
to not to show up to the school anymore
maybe you're going to say you know what
look i'm going to take the risk of the
vaccine
or at your work or wherever and these
are very thorny difficult
political questions that require some
prudence
but that's not good enough for the
public health establishment no no
they need you to believe that a
otherwise perfectly healthy young person
is at grave risk of dying from the wu
flu
none of the data backed this up but
here's the article
dr brittany kobia said monday that all
but one of her covid patients
in alabama did not receive the vaccine
the unvaccinated patient she said
just needs a little oxygen and is
expected to fully recover some of the
others are dying
quote i'm admitting young healthy people
to the hospital with very serious covet
infections
wrote cobia hospitalistic grandview
medical center in birmingham
in an emotional facebook post on sunday
facebook posts now are
that's the sourcing and the evidence for
serious journalistic articles
yes the facebook post says one of the
last things they do
before they're intubated is beg me for
the vaccine
i hold their hand and tell them that i'm
sorry
but it's too late
i will take things that never happened
for 500 alex could i
okay oh good i found it here's the thing
that never happened and i
and i tell them rights by the way she
doesn't look so upset about this you
look at what's britney kobe as she looks
smiling in the picture not great stuff
from the photo editor but it
kind of highlights how preposterous this
is that reporters
are quoting random unverified facebook
posts
as though that's going to give you
information about what's actually going
on in public health
i'm gonna you know i want them to start
reporting on how i sent this article to
my
to my son and my son said daddy daddy
why won't people assume the risk of
myocarditis
before the sigma and the lambda and the
delta variants become the dominant
strains and my son is six months old
and when he said that everyone in line
at tsa applauded
it's true report it it's on facebook you
have to believe it
preposterous preposterous if this were
a serious epidemic level threat for
otherwise healthy young people you would
see that reflected
in the data but you're not there are no
data to back that up
so you're seeing it reflected in
fabulous
facebook posts and being reported by the
hack
corporate media as though it were the
gospel
truth there is
a big push right now to downplay the
risks of the experimental drug
and to get everyone to take the jab for
some people it's worth the risk
be it for medical political whatever
reasons for other people
it's not worth the risk if you're
otherwise totally healthy
and you have no reason impelling you to
take it
eric clapton gosh i love eric clapton
i always i always liked eric clapton and
now i love eric clapton he's been pretty
strong against the lock downs he and van
morrison another
terrific guy uh put out songs about how
awful the coveted lockdowns are and how
technocratic globalist alates are taking
all of our rights so eric clapton
took the vaccine he was impelled to do
it
and he had had a pre-existing condition
some issue with with his nerves i
believe it was
and he got the vaccine and he had a very
adverse reaction he couldn't play guitar
for a few weeks he just his hand was
almost paralyzed
and so he's very very anti-vaccine
mandate right now
and clapton just came out and he said
that he would cancel
any shows if the venue requires that
attendees prove
that they are vaccinated against covid19
i love that
this is what's going to do it more than
making any arguments about the data and
the statistics and the threat from the
virus and more than making any
abstract arguments about constitutional
rights and how this is unjust and how dr
fauci
has never appeared on a ballot no one's
ever voted for him he shouldn't be
running our country
more than that what is going to end this
madness
if this madness is to be ended is going
to be the exercise of the political
power you have
eric clapton has some political power
he's a very famous musician and people
want to see his shows
a lot of venues at the behest of the
public health establishment
and the government and even other
corporations are going to try to require
proof of vaccination especially in the
united kingdom
and eric clapton is saying okay well if
you want to do that you just won't get
eric clapton shows
that's fine you do that and then i'm
just going to stay home
and play my beautiful music by myself
and count my money and have a perfectly
fine life your choice
and then the venue is going to lose out
on a lot of money and the advertisers
are going to lose out on a lot of money
and the corporations that that
sell our products are going to lose out
on a lot of money but that's fine do
what you want to do
that's a good use of political power
rand paul
making the doj referral that's a good
use of
political power kevin mccarthy pulling
the republicans
off of this committee that's a good use
of political power because if we do not
exercise that political power
the countries are going to shut down
again over very
very few cases and very very few deaths
as is going on right now
in australia you can get all all the
news first thing in the morning
when you tune in to morning wire it's
our new podcast brought to you by daily
wire editor in chief john bickley
co-host georgia howe morningwire will
wake you up with the latest developments
in politics sports culture and education
all with a heavy emphasis on the facts
so some of our shows
are opinion shows where we present the
facts but then
we use the facts as a launching board
for philosophy for religion for
literature for history
that's what we do on this show so what
you get on the other daily wire shows
well this is just
the news all the news that's fit to put
in a 15 minute podcast
great for your daily commute the podcast
just launched this week
it's already number two on apple
and number 11 on spotify and while you
are
there by the way while you're listening
we're so happy about that
we need you to help us get the news you
need to know
which to where it belongs we need it at
number one so subscribe now to morning
wire on
apple spotify wherever you listen your
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear
and you can also pre-order ben's new
book which is great to do after you buy
my book speechless
you can pre-order the authoritarian
moment it's bookshelves next tuesday
july 27th go to dailywire.com
ben to order your signed copy today he's
going to be doing a live book signing
event
next tuesday the 27th so you pre-order
your copy now you write a question to
check out
then you catch the live signing on the
live stream and hopefully ben will
answer your question
dailywire.com ben right now get the
authoritarian moment which
is my campaign slogan in 2028 we'll be
right back with a lot more
australia is shutting down again
australia is totally locking down
like it's going to be hard to leave your
home locking down
why australia is a pretty rough and
tumble place it was a
land mass settled by british criminals
it has flying foxes and gigantic spiders
and all sorts of things that are going
to try to kill you
and they survive because they're tough
people out there right
until the wuflu killed
one more person one more death
and the country shuts down good evening
within hours
sydney will be in the group of much
tougher restrictions
the premier clamping down on the
stubborn delta outbreak
with what she's calling a no regrets
policy
and this is why from a record 82 000
tests the state today recorded 111 cases
and tragically the third covert death in
this outbreak
a man aged in his 80s from the city's
southeast
across greater sydney retail shops will
now close
a small list of essential stores can
remain open
construction sites across the city shut
down
and from midnight tonight 110 suburbs
across liverpool
fairfield and canterbury bankstown will
be sealed
shut that's 900 000 residents
who can't leave their area even for work
so you've got hundreds of thousands of
tests
well over a hundred thousand tests
you've got
a relatively small number of cases some
hundreds of cases
and you've got one more death
the third of this outbreak but now just
this one more
one death from this round of testing
so they're going to shut down everywhere
they're going to shut down whole suburbs
you can't go to work you were locked
basically in your home shut down retail
shops
because the lady running australia wants
to have no
regrets something tells me that the
people who can't pay their bills are
going to have some regrets something
tells me that people who can't go to
church
probably going to have some regrets the
people who can't be with their loved
ones while they die
some regrets the people who can't get
married some regrets
the people who can't bury their dead
some regrets
you get the point the people who can't
live their lives i think
are going to have some regrets in the
amount of time that it took
to watch just that clip from that
segment on australia's channel 9 news
90 people died not from kovid
they just died because people die people
die all the time they die from a whole
host of causes
they die from heart attacks they die
from cancers they die from car accidents
they die from pianos falling on their
head while they walk across the street
they just
people die that's a fact mortality is a
fact of life that in modernity we try to
deny as best we can
but it's true all of life is a
preparation for dying
get used to it you will have a much
better life if you accept this fact
and because hanging concentrates the
mind you will also
want hopes look beyond just this mortal
coil
to the metaphysical underpinnings of our
world but we can't do that in our our
age
so while the wuflu kills relatively
very few people very very few people as
a proportion of those who are dying
australia's shutting down again that
will happen here if we do not exercise
our political power and push back
there are much more troubling issues of
the government making
decisions of life and death let's go
from australia
all the way back to the motherland where
right now
a hospital in the united kingdom and
a judge in the united kingdom is trying
to they are both trying to kill
a little girl so parents are fighting to
keep their two-year-old daughter alive
the two-year-old daughter has very
difficult health problems
has some brain issues and so
the hospital and the judge are are
saying that they're going to
withdraw life support family i think
they're
orthodox jews they do not want their
baby to be killed by the health
establishment
but because the government runs the
health care system in the uk
the government can decide whether or not
to kill your baby and this has happened
multiple times remember it was a little
baby alfie
there was another little baby just over
the last four or five years
the the uk will kill them and and you'll
have people in the united states
remember donald trump said bring the
babies here we'll take care of the
babies
the uk said no we're not going to do
that but pope francis said bring the
baby
to a hospital outside of the vatican
we'll we will
take care of the baby there nope sorry
because the government bureaucrats in
the uk
have much much more power and so you can
make all the arguments all day long that
you want this is unjust this is wrong
this is terrible please the rights of
the
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter if
you don't have political power
then you can't exercise those rights i'm
not saying that might makes right quite
the opposite actually i'm not saying
that
just because you have the power that
means you have the right to do something
there are rights that you have
but those rights cannot be exercised if
you don't also have a bit of might if
you don't also have
some political power meanwhile speaking
of killing
babies needlessly it's always needless
to kill a little there's no i don't i've
never heard a good argument
for killing a little baby but i've heard
a lot of arguments for it
notably in the abortion debate right now
a pro-abortion state senator
by the name of senator joe cervantes
is very upset because he's nominally
catholic even though he scandalously
flouts church teaching
on very important matters not just one
issue among many but on the right
to life the prerequisite for all of the
other rights
and he's whining because his priests and
his bishop
will not give him the eucharist he's not
permitted to receive holy communion
he writes quote i was denied communion
last night by the catholic bishop here
in la cruces
and based on my political office my new
parish priest has indicated he will do
the same after the last was run off
please pray for church authorities
as catholicism transitions under pope
francis
this creates a problem first of all
let's get to the first part of that
first priests and bishops have
repeatedly warned this guy
they've said hey you are you are
scandalously flatting to
church teaching this is not even just a
private sin of yours
it's not a private sin that you've
repented first of all it's not a private
sin even that you're obstinately
persistent in it is a public sin
that is creating the sin of scandal and
misleading the flock and it is our job
if bishops and priests
have any job whatsoever it is to guide
the flock feed the sheep and care for
their souls
so when the priests say you are not
permitted to receive
holy communion that is an act of mercy
and compassion
not just for the flock not just for the
other parishioners
but also for this state senator who is
imperiling his mortal soul and in the
words of saint paul
eating his own damnation when he
receives
the eucharist outside of a state of
grace it is an act of mercy
that they are performing on him right
now
and by the way if this state senator
doesn't believe in church teaching
doesn't care about it is willing to
flout very important church teaching up
to and including
supporting a bill right now because it's
happening right now he's supporting a
bill
that would make it easier to kill babies
in the womb
if you don't care about church teaching
then why do you care about the holy
communion
because you recognize deep down
somewhere you recognize
that there is a moral order deep down
you recognize
that there is some objective truth that
you can't just do whatever you want all
the time and be
perfectly fine you just don't want to
to have that truth in any way impinge on
your life
well sorry buster that's the way the
world works
now the second part here is even more
troubling because
this guy seems to believe that pope
francis would support his side
pope francis has been very confusing
he's been very unclear about a lot of
things
now he what he usually does the holy
father
is he will give an interview to an
atheist
leftist italian journalist by the name
specifically one named eugenio sklofari
who runs la republica
very popular center-left newspaper in
italy and then
it'll have all sorts of crazy claims
about how the pope thinks no one's in
hell or how the pope is totally fine
with homosexuality or how the pope is
whatever you know
and then but then the vatican will come
out and be no the papa the holy father
was a misinterpreted
no i don't know why these journalists
are
a continuing to publisher these are
misinterpretations
well sure i have no doubt that that
these journalists
don't get things right in part just out
of ignorance because they don't know a
lot about the catholic faith and then
sometimes out of malice as well
but then why does the holy father keep
giving them interviews
see that's the problem that's why the
confusion of this pontificate
i think goes all the way up to the top i
think
it might even seem to be a bit of a
strategy
i i don't think that the holy father
supports killing babies in the womb i
don't think that at all
but i see why this very ignorant
nominally catholic state senator might
think that because there's been a lot of
confusion
and this gets to another point a lot of
people have written in to me to ask
about this
especially a lot of my protestant
listeners have written in here
because they heard this news article
last week that the pope has banned the
latin mass and they want to know what
does that mean why does that matter
what's going on here
the the long and short of it is you had
the traditional latin mass which is
about a lot more than just language okay
i know we call it the latin master the
english mass
but the latin mass is the traditional
mass which includes a lot of different
reverent practices a lot of
more reverent liturgy the order of
public worship it involves
uh it's an entire
form of prayer that is physicalized in
the
in the mass then in the 1960s
the second vatican council upended
everything and
changed a lot of aspects of the mass not
just the language but so much of the
reverence led in all sorts of abuses
and the church is emptied and and so i
was raised in the new hippie dippy mass
with the sappy 70s hymns that weren't
even cool 50 years ago
and it is not very beautiful and then
a lot of people fell away from the
church during the sex scandals of the
early 2000s
during the week liturgy during the rise
of new atheism that ridiculous
publishing movement with christopher
hitchens and all the rest of them
and then in the meantime while i was
away from the church i came back to the
church around 2013 or so
pope benedict reauthorized the use of
the latin mass and the background on
this is it led to a lot of young people
coming back to the church
led to a lot of converts because it's
beautiful because it's grand
it's like the difference between
classical architecture and ugly modern
architecture okay classical architecture
think of the supreme court
building wow it's grand it's big it's
beautiful it fills you with awe it's
inspiring
it lifts you up beyond the mundane and
then you think of ugly hideous modern
architecture like the night stuff in the
70s and stuff
and that's ugly and it brings you down
and it doesn't cause you to look up at
the heavens and consider grand things
it's just kind of
small it makes the world that i think is
a fair analog
for the for these types of liturgy so
young people come back
to be inspired by this gorgeous chanting
and this reverence and this music and
the smells and the bells
and all the rest of it and the irony
here
is that all of these 85 year old
reformers these a lot of them ex-hippie
types from
the 1960s and 70s they constantly tell
you
if you want to reach the youths you've
got to have tie-dye shirts and acoustic
guitars that's what's going to make you
reach the youths well i'm telling you
i've been to masses all around this
country
some of the new english masses some of
the old latin masses i prefer the old
latin masses
the median age at the latin mass is like
25 and they've all got a dozen kids how
is that biologically possible i have no
idea but they do
it's young it's crying it's got babies
it's great and then if you go to the new
the new mask quote unquote from the 60s
in english with the acoustic guitars and
the felt banners and all the rest of it
the median age is like 82 and there's no
babies whatsoever and
it no one's really taking it all that
seriously
and yet the boomers still are dominating
this matters i think to people who are
not catholic as well
it reflects like the architecture issue
it reflects this this broader
division in our society between the the
age of aquarius types the people in the
60s and 70s who said we're going to
knock down every institution we're going
to rebuild society from the very
beginning
we're going to get rid of every vestige
of the past the only way that america
can ever be great is if we get rid of
our whole past
we can't learn anything from tradition
it's just a bunch of white racist
rich evil patriarchal men
and then there's the tradition and a lot
of people especially a lot of young
people especially a lot of people who
listen to this show
realize oh the tradition is a pretty
beautiful thing
this ugly modern desiccated world this
is not quite so beautiful but
aristotle plato thomas aquinas bach
brahms wow there's some really good
stuff here guys wow
the glories of our civilization huh
maybe we can learn something from that
spirit of humility compared to the pride
of modernity
that humility before the tradition that
is something that people long for
there's an african member of the
catholic episcopal
cardinal sarah cardinal sarah is
a really wonderful very traditional guy
he's butted heads with pope francis at
times
a lot of people myself included have
thought he would be a great candidate
for
the pope and it would it would be kind
of funny because he's black obviously so
we'd say you know how dare you liberals
not want to support the first black pope
but he's more conservative than
virtually anybody
anybody in the college of cardinals but
cardinal sarah made this point about
tradition versus ugly modernity and
cardinal sarah said quote
i am an african let me say clearly the
liturgy is not the place to promote my
culture
rather it is the place where my culture
is baptized
where my culture is taken up into the
divine
the power of silence against the
dictatorship of noise
beautiful beautiful stuff so you see
this in liturgy you know the
reformers want to have like i don't know
sombreros and and uh maracas or
something you know
in in the mexican liturgies and then i
don't know all sorts of stuff all around
the world they want
they want the church to become more
worldly and what cardinal sarah's saying
is no no
make my culture more divine make my
culture more heavily lift my culture up
this is true in the issue of immigration
there are some people who believe that
we need to bring immigrants into this
country and then we all need to
assimilate to them
and we need to have not a mixing melting
pot but a salad bowl where it's just you
know in this neighborhood it's going to
be all mexican
and in this neighborhood it's going to
be all irish in this neighborhood it's
going to be all black and in this
neighborhood
and then it's we're all just going to
preserve our culture no
it's not how it works it's got to got to
mix a little bit we've got to assimilate
we're either going to have
a nation or we're not going to have a
nation people are coming to america for
a reason they're not coming to america
from guatemala because guatemala is so
great
they're coming to america because they
think america is better than guatemala
so don't turn america into guatemala it
doesn't make sense
why are people coming to the church to
lift their eyes up to heaven
to escape worldliness and yet so many of
the reformers want to turn the church
into just another
non-governmental organization or
something this is the importance of
education right now
you've heard this whole debate over
critical race theory a lot of the
reformers will say
no critical race theory it's not real
it's not it's just a
academic movement that's taught in a
handful of law schools it's not
affecting your kids
ignore it ignore it ignore it well
there's a report out now a virginia
public school district sent a powerpoint
to teachers explaining how to
explicitly implement critical race
theory in the classroom
this is the fairfax county public school
sent out the resource
as a teacher-facing item so it's not
meant to be seen by the kids and not
meant to be seen by the parents
and certainly not meant to be seen by
you or me as we're reporting it on this
show
but it's talking about critical race
theory how to include quote
culturally relevant pedagogy
institutional systemic racism
anti-racism education anti-hate
education
blah blah blah and the district rightly
defines critical race theory as a quote
interpretive framework that examines the
appearance of race and racism across
dominant
cultural modes of expression and in
adopting this approach
critical race theory scholars attempt to
understand how victims of systemic
racism are affected by cultural
perceptions of prejudice and all the
rest of it
so don lemon recently on cnn was trying
to peddle this silly idea the critical
race theory it's not being taught in
schools
no it's just some a couple people at
harvard law school but that's it it's
not being taught to your kids or
anything
and russ douthit from the new york times
the more conservative
writer at the new york times he smacked
that down
you're encouraging kids white kids to
have
sort of to to in effect cultivate a kind
of sense of their own whiteness with the
idea being that
if you encourage that these kids will
then
be able to sort of recognize their own
white privilege
and transcend it but that's a lot of
where the controversy is right it's
about
these programs that aren't teaching
about the history of racism aren't even
teaching about sort of
contemporary they're uh
saying you know white kids especially
need to think of themselves
in these categories and in these ways
and that's
i think a big part of what people are
reacting against yeah listen i don't
know if that in fact is happening but i
mean ross we should say that critical
race theory is not being taught
uh it's not part of the curriculum for
uh elementary or grade school students
it's something that's taught
in law schools just so we know but
that's not exactly right critical race
theory
is an incredibly influential set of
ideas that has
ex solid influence in
education schools and elsewhere no but
but ross i'm gonna just completely
ignore everything you've said for the
past 40 seconds and just just beep boop
critical race theory not in schools beep
beep boop and then
ross death who's very thoughtful person
says what did you not just listen to
no it that's not right don it obviously
is
ideas have consequences and even ideas
that begin in a law school will have an
effect well certainly an idea that
begins in a law school is going to have
an effect on the broader
legal community and on the law and the
way that we govern ourselves in our
country and it's
going to have an effect on pedagogy down
the line as it has including in
elementary schools
here's one of the ideas so ibram kendi
who is i think he's the second or third
leading civil rights leader in this
country as you all know i'm the number
one
i'm the preeminent civil rights leader
in this country according to
the book charts on amazon so uh ibram
candy he's one of the lesser civil
rights leaders i suppose
and he says i'm not a critical race
theorist
and then other people say no he is a
critical race theorist and the reality
is he is
pushing ideas that have been popularized
and developed by the critical race
theorists
namely whiteness bad whiteness pervasive
blackness
always equals victimhood kennedy has
gone so far he even now says that
what is criminal is defined by race
i don't know if i necessarily agree with
with scholars
who make the case that black communities
have
criminogenic conditions and the reason
i'm saying this is because what is
criminalized
is has historically been been based on
on race and power
and even how certain criminalized or
decriminalized sort of acts have also
been
sort of racialized so when people hear
about that person who was drinking and
driving or
that person who killed somebody uh
because they were drinking and driving
it doesn't
cause them to think they don't perceive
that
as them thereby living in a dangerous
neighborhood so i'm just
emphasizing this ezra because even what
we consider to be
violence even what we consider to be
crime
is highly racialized and therefore what
neighborhoods we consider to be criminal
like and dangerous
becomes highly racialized you know what
you know what i'm going to say this in
the spirit of charity
ibram kendy has a point here
what we consider criminal has become
very racialized for instance
burning down the country in the name of
black lives matter and killing lots of
people and stealing lots of
property that's not considered criminal
anymore because the people doing it
are at least in large part black and
because they're doing it in the name of
black lives matter so that's good that's
mostly peaceful
and dancing around the capitol and
taking pelosi's elector and that's
considered the worst act of terrorism in
american history
because a lot of those people were white
and it was done on behalf of a white
president yeah kenny you're making a
good point
not sure if it's the point you think
you're making but but you're making a
good point we'll have to leave it there
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 john bickley here editor-in-chief
of the daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode senator rand paul and
dr anthony fauci
spar over gain of function research
teachers groups gather to discuss
race and social justice and negotiations
over the infrastructure bill
appear to be wrapping up join us and get
the facts first on the news you need to
know
with our show morning wire